buenas tardes ha sido un momento
histórico es el primer dirigente primer
líder internacional en dirigirse al
parlamento británico ni siquiera la
reina isabel que la jefe de estado de
este país lo ha hecho ha sido un momento
bien emotivo ha iniciado con una ovación
la cámara de los comunes absolutamente
llena ningún diputado quería perderse
este momento tan emotivo el presidente
es el esquí como mencionas ha detallado
día por día lo que han sido estos 13
días de guerra estos 13 días de horror
pero también le ha pedido al reino unido
que siga aumentando las sanciones a
rusia y que además lo declare como un
estado terrorista su discurso ha tenido
referencias que han recordado los
discursos ahí en la cámara de los
comunes del del el del líder de la
segunda guerra mundial winston churchill
quien ha dicho y quien dijo en repetidas
ocasiones en ese mismo lugar que no se
rendiría y eso también ha dicho el
presidente es el esquí que no se
rendirán ante esta situación hasta esta
guerra con rusia pero también ha
recordado a william shakespeare ha dicho
que en estos 13 días se han preguntado
sobre sí ser o no ser y que
definitivamente han decidido un país de
ser y que no se rendirán